you've been talking about the weather in
Washington there is other weather nearly
45 million Americans are in the path of
a deadly storm system that's been
tearing through the southern plains for
three days that system is blamed for at
least two deaths it spawned multiple
tornadoes while dumping heavy rain and
uprooting trees Omar Villafranca is in
Morton Mississippi the scene of
widespread damage Omar good morning good
morning this home took a direct hit and
I'm standing in what used to be the
living room luckily the homeowner ran
for shelter in one of those closets back
there and the police chief actually had
to pull her out amazingly no one was
seriously injured here now emergency
officials are telling us that at least
50 structures everything from homes to
garages were damaged or destroyed in
this storm a view from the sky the
horror people endured in Morton from a
tornado uprooted trees surround
flattened homes some homes are missing
roofs or walls others are destroyed cell
phone video from one homeowner shows the
moment the entire front of her house was
torn off
in nearby Jackson torrential downpours
and strong winds snapped trees in half
we suddenly heard the big crack and then
a jaunt thud and sheared off the brick
siding of an apartment building crushing
cars below across Louisiana winds ripped
trees from the ground in Alexandria one
tree pierced the roof of this home I
heard what I thought was thunder and
then I felt the house shake and then
that's when I got up to come see what
was going on and notice there was a tree
in the kitchen the storm traveled more
than 700 miles over 24 hours leaving a
trail of crumpled buildings and shredded
homes across Texas including this one
which rolled from its foundation with a
young couple still inside it just kind
of kept on rolling my wife was in the
bathroom it threw me into the wall and
then out the window the National Weather
Service believes that multiple tornadoes
touched down in this part of Mississippi
and in fact they'll have crews out here
later on today to survey the damage and
see exactly how powerful those tornadoes
were Gale yep Omar mother nature she is
no joke thank you very much